je ne sais pas pourquoi c'est une
coïncidence si c'est le hasard du
calendrier c'est parce que ma femme est
sur le plateau mais on m'a donné un
sondage qui c'est qui téléphonent donc
tout va bien
il ya 41 % des français qui fantasment
murray sur leurs collègues de travail
oit 41 41 et c'est très précis alors
est-ce que certains étaient déjà arrivés
ici présent leur jeu
le gepan et des invités parce qu'on sait
qu'au cinéma
on vous connaît donc je passerai je pose
aucune question je ne veux rien savoir
mais moi c'est comme si on venait donc
là je t'entends de forêts claires voilà
c'est faux c'est formidable
ludivine bonsoir vous et fred mais
nabiye ce soir c'est un bonheur merci
beaucoup meilleur achat sans vous êtes
sans pathos c'est un bonheur a mérité
deux beaux noms dans ma vie j'ai vous et
ma famille prête donc je sais malgré
liberia calmez-vous je vais arriver sur
votre cas dans pas très longtemps
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui bravo pour une
fois ou deux tabliers sobre vu le bas
aubry y en a partout à les grilles et
six en chine
derrière lui c'est là donc oui alors
domcile valeurs est-ce que vous avez
fantasmer sur quelqu'un du travail oui
c'est pas une machine geenen arriver
gilles verdez pas encore pour gillou 7
ans et au revoir qui ne progresse que ça
progresse beaucoup mais ça m'arrivait il
ya plusieurs années
j'étais déjà en couple la personne aussi
mais j'ai eu le bonheur de co présentait
une cérémonie vous savez avec satya
oblet tâche n'est pas du tout question
mais je vous dis que c'est lui c'est
quand même un modèle international
pas de quoi en faire des tonnes non plus
vous êtes
alors passez un fossé après quoi ils
[Rires]
nagent pas notre linge sale en famille
maintenant à la disqueuse et c'est pour
nous lâche pas son linge à revivre cet
os je ne veux plus de vous et donc
c'était très difficile pour moi de
rester focus
bon j'ai rien tenté pour la prise il est
beau gosse mais il n'a rien tenté le
sujet à brazza oui oui j'étais déjà pris
c'était poisson est horrible je trouve
sondages et du privé menace était en
congé l'image à la mairie aussi mais
c'est réglé
d'accord donc c'était sa doublette sa
doublette que j'en vois c'est que
j'embrasse très fort malgré les verts
d'amont soir
[Applaudissements]
alors quels débuts l'émission rouge
alors ça va
oui ça va bien et vous la journée super
bien vous étiez aux ongles j'étais en
dédicace pour deux pieds très très bon
très bon très bon livre
merci c'est ma vie en réalité oui merci
ça mais je vous en prie ensemble
alors donc la question était avez vous
déjà fantasmé radio c'est pas mon délire
du tout je suis désolé mais pas du tout
bon soyons les connais pas tu veux être
méchante mais non mais je vous aime bien
les gars mais bon cela fait forcément je
n'ai pas du tout ça peut être mes
enfants mes mais vous prenez ça va non
pas du tout aux enfants non même
candidat télé réalité ça c'est pas les
pas du tout qui est moi je suis marié ps
qui on n'empêche que sur ce plateau je
vous sens mal à l'aise avec les beaux
gosses que vous croisez les tablettes de
chocolat et vanille et la petite partie
bien fait et vas-y tu le fais c'est de
nos pires mais je cesserai tout de suite
mais en soit je pense que sur photos
je suis là c'est une marie plus
longtemps et donc pardon si vous faites
une elise encore au mariage cela me
faisait passer à l'action
non non vous aux fantasmes non merci
maxime dillies bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien d'avoir du cela c'est bien
alors maxime p dg partie du clan est un
pourri déjà et vous savez ce que c'est
un fantasme généralement les fantasmes
ne devienne pas réalité sinon ils n'ont
aucun intérêt
mais un jour j'ai mis un râteau accrue
et là lorsque je travaille à buzz
déclare dans nos têtes qu'on parle de
nom de cruella descend dalmatiens ça et
des buzz est clair berlin philip toone
que tu peux y aurait un toit du travail
et disneyland en 2006 2007
jupp heynckes du marc hé oui d'accord
dont cinq cents par action c'est ma
soeur et pour atteindre le lieu de
travail
on doit prendre un bus qui fait tour le
tour du parc et parfois il ya des arrêts
et ombassa l'arrêt arts spectacles et
parades et j'ai simple d'aller avec une
sacrée cruella elle en voulait mais dans
lens les pas besoin jal à la législation
est passé directement à gilbert nous
sommes
alors d'içi gillain ouais très classe
soir moi ce qu'ils m'ont dit qu'ils
allaient recommença suis pas ce que je
dis j'arrive dans la femme qu'est ce
qu'elle va sortir pour mental je pense
que je vais sauter la personne et vous
aimez l'envoyer été facile
nous sommes en 54 nous sommes au début
des années 80 des ballons soleil tape
sur les champs de pommes de terre des
cellules avec à l'époque pour faire un
peu d'argent de poche j'étais ramasseur
de pomme de terre d'un très haut niveau
obama sur d'onces arrivent oh oui oui en
sac ou en machine j'étais très réputé et
sur la machine je fantasme est
littéralement sur une de mes collègues
de travail qui s'appelait sylvie même
pas d'être madame patate directement à
l'époque j'étais nul en eau à l'époque
j'étais mieux landragin peu comme gagner
aujourd'hui très maladroit et donc je ne
savais pas quoi faire mais j'étais sûr
qu'elle me regardait en permanence un
besoin de ludivine mais tu tournes on
est donc j'avais un copain
j'avais un copain d'enfance qui était
avec moi français et tous les soirs g10
elle est folle de moi les folles de one
day mais lance toi lance toi lance toi
au bout de deux mois je me lance et je
vais dire à celui-ci lui le mois bah oui
juillet-août vie confortable comme la
vôtre castaldi
je travaillais vous savez si vous voyez
monsieur dans une banque
absolument et donc je vais la fois oui
au bout de deux mois et je lui dis je
suis fou de veau et elle me dit mais
gilles ça fait deux mois que je sors
avec françois il ne t'a rien on est en
fait elle se sentait voilà le gard le
gars je ne lis jamais par les batteries
je le comprends les mimiques tuer votre
week-end aura été